hey youtubers is charlie thank you
everyone that submitted questions for
this week's Walking Dead Q&A so we know
a couple things about the season finale
so far like the titles of the episodes
as well as what most of the action is
going to be there's also the issue of
Morgan coming back and tyler james
williams position on the show whether or
not he's going to stay on after the
finale so time for questions careful for
spoilers if you haven't seen the episode
yet starting with number one Chris asks
so how did Darryl come up with making
fires to distract the walkers that's
probably just a trick that he learned
over the last couple years on the show
or since the apocalypse started I didn't
think of it as anything super sneaky but
there's a lot of small everyday skills
that they picked up just from having
done it so many times part of the appeal
of the show the last four or five
seasons are that we've watched these
people get better and better at
surviving that's why the ones that
weren't so good did not survive everyone
gets just like a little bit smarter each
season or at least you hope so although
it's not always about who's the
strongest or the smartest there is
always like an element of luck involved
in people surviving from season to
season look as in say getting hit by a
car that also just happens to be an
improvised ambulance question number two
freedom access the video may be
extremely nervous for Carol why would
they put all these flashbacks in unless
something bad was going to happen that's
a good question they would not put the
minute if something bad was not going to
happen everything that makes it into an
episode is carefully picked like it's
not by accident you can make a lot of
arguments for other characters biting
the dust but I feel like all signs are
pointing to Carol being the one that's
gonna die I mean they wouldn't give her
all this time and build her character up
this way if they weren't getting ready
to pull the rug out from underneath us
it's just a classic TV thing anytime you
see a character get giant moments like
this and it's like sad it's not some
hero moment his prime means they're
getting ready to die unless it's Game of
Thrones then anybody could die at any
minute for any reason Walking Dead does
a good job of paying off things that it
foreshadows like if you remember
Abraham's hand in that one scene you
know that wasn't by accident like the
reason his hand was shown all those
different times they're gonna pay that
off eventually question number three
lexie ass after they get Beth out of the
hospital do you think that they'll let
know live and possibly join the group or
just kill him I definitely don't think
they're going to kill him but I don't
expect tyler james williams to stay on
the show for a long time I do not expect
Tyler Jane
Williams to replace Bob in the group a
long shot that I'm hoping for is that
Morgan is related to Noah and Noah will
go off with him after the mid-season
finale I don't think that Morgan is
going to stay with the group of all the
things that are probably going to happen
in the finale I feel like that's one of
the least likely things either way I
don't think that Noah's going to be with
the group permanently question number
four ritesh ass do you think that
Abraham's group will reunite with Rick
at the church and help out I was
actually kind of back and forth of this
I had to watch the episode a couple more
times and then watch the Abraham episode
I actually do think that they will end
up helping them out of the mid-season
finale for those that have read the
comics I think it'll be closer to what
the comics are they did say at the
beginning of the season they be doing
more comic moments and even if the
hospital battle isn't straight out of
the comics I feel like the next leg of
the journey is going to be something
right out of the comics like that big
place they go in the comics I feel like
that's where they're going next if you
have read ahead just please use spoiler
tags in the comments when talking about
it although i feel it's pretty obvious
where they're all going next just add to
that the producer said that they're not
doing the exact same thing with Abraham
that they did in the comics so if you
have read the comics his character will
be slightly different like what ends up
happening to him later on question
number five libya's what happened to the
people in the sleeping bags there were
bullet holes they obviously didn't die
of natural causes i would say that there
was probably like a revolt inside that
walkway and someone just killed all the
other people sometimes the producers
will do that they'll answer questions
about like the walkers you see and
backgrounds like what happened to them
what their story was it seemed like they
had a little small community that was
trying to hold out so either they
starved or there was a revolt over them
running out of food like they were
running out of food and someone went
crazy I would say that's probably one of
the number one causes of groups turning
on themselves in the apocalypse is
running out of food question number six
psycho ass will the hospital stuff be
wrapped up this half or do you think
it'll drag on throughout the rest of the
season so that's a good question episode
8 is called coda the symbol for Kota
resembles a set of crosshairs it's used
as a navigation marker in music episode
7 the one before that is called crossed
as in hospital crosses you have crossed
a line crossing people off a list as in
killing people it seems like all those
things point to the hospital turning
into a reverse terminus in the finale
like they may not blow it
but it's definitely not going to drag on
for another eight episodes question
number 7 Michaela asks why kuma show and
stay back I would think she'd be a
valuable asset so yeah and that clip
with Karl like the teaser for the next
episode it seems like the group had left
to go to the hospital that might not
necessarily be what's happening in that
scene the biggest reason I can think of
to leave her behind is just a guard baby
Judith Carl and Gabriel one Gabriel
looks like he wouldn't pick up a weapon
so he's not going to be helped to
anybody and to even though Rick does
trust Carl like Carla can handle himself
with a gun Gabriel and baby Judith ooh
there and he feels like that's probably
too much for Karl to handle by himself
it all just comes down to Rick not
trusting anyone I think that's the only
reason we show and stay back and she has
a soft spot for Karl and baby Judith
like she's their mom by proxy are you
reach own shippers out there can take
that as you want question number eight
ala fox junior ass do you think that
Morgan will have his episodes soon yes I
think that he'll either show up at the
end of episode 7 in like a post-credits
WTF scene or I'll show up in episode 8
like guns blazing it's the mid-season
finale so they're gonna want to match
the energy from season four and it's
really hard to beat the governor it
would be a total waste if he just walked
up at the end and said hey what's up
guys what he been doing I remember in
the lead-up to season five everyone was
hoping that Morgan would be the one to
save the people at the prison it turned
out to be Carol which i think is great
but I think that that moment with Morgan
will happen this time in this mid-season
finale just think Morgan rambo-type
moment question number 9 Alexander asks
if sonequa martin-green is pregnant then
are they gonna kill Sasha or just put
her on the sideline for a bit this is a
good question so I had a theory after
like the Bob episode that they had sex
before he died before i got captured i
think the baby is going to be an answer
to that there was a rumor that someone
on the show was gonna get pregnant
people thought it was gonna be Maggie
and Glenn was gonna die I think that
that's just happening with Bob and Sasha
people were asking her what was going on
with her pregnancy like at the show a
deal with it she said that it would she
just didn't say how think they will
address it eventually based on the time
line right now she's not going to be
showing for a while like they just had
the wrap party they're slowly finishing
like the final bits of the last episode
episode 16 for the back half of the
season so if they do end up showing her
pregnant you wouldn't see it to like
episode
11-12 that being said I don't expect to
see anything about Sasha being pregnant
in this mid-season finale like if they
do it would be like a really offhanded
reference but just keep your eyes peeled
she could be pregnant the next big
question though is what would they do
with two babies on the show I don't
think that that's going to happen like
they're not gonna have two babies in the
group walking around once we see what
really ends up happening we can make
some more theories I don't want a theory
craft too much on something that we
don't know anything about question
number 10 up in the air ass how do you
think that Morgan will help and do you
think that Rick will recognize dawn lady
negan from the hospital so I think I
already kind of explained the Morgan
things so I'll talk about the lady cop
there was a picture from the webisodes
where Rick was standing next to a lady
sheriff officer or sheriff's deputy it
was believed that that might be dawn
learned her the police officer that's
been harassing Beth I do not think that
that's the case yes King County is right
next to Atlanta but if you look at the
pictures from her office it shows her
from before the apocalypse with another
police officer in order for her to be
the person in this webisode picture from
Shannon Rick sheriff station she would
have had to have been a sheriff right
before the apocalypse Rick was in a coma
for less than a year and Dawn had been a
police officer in Atlanta at that time
so i don't think the timelines match up
enough even if they don't know each
other I feel like they're gonna have
like that moment of bonding where it's
like you're an officer of the law I'm an
officer of the law so they do share a
lot of similarities they just took
radically different paths thank you so
much everyone for so many questions
these are always a ton of fun to do
remember next week episode 7 basically
going to be like part one of a two-part
finale I think that's the way I'm
looking at it after episode 8 in two
weeks I will be doing more bonus videos
so if there's anything special that you
guys want to see feel free to make
requests in the comments below and be
sure to subscribe to get all that stuff
right now congratulations to this week's
giveaway winners Stephen Marston you and
that amazon gift card be sure to reach
out to me on my channel for details I am
working on a new game of Thrones video
and Gotham is tonight so i'll be posting
that first i'll try to get Game of
Thrones up by tomorrow morning but
youtube is letting me test out a new
beta feature so I'm adding some extra
links up here so you guys can click up
here to test all that stuff out all
those videos that I'm talking about so
let me know what you think thank you so
much for watching so let's all high five
I will see you guys tonight
you